like any good Souls like lies of P has a
few different endings each with cryptic
details to uncover and explain the
ending you get is determined by your
choices in the game and the lies or
truths you tell in this video I will be
going through each of the three endings
and explaining them from the
straightforward facts to the Obscure
details to even the sequel hints I hope
you enjoy and if you do feel free to
subscribe to see more content like this
obviously be warned for spoilers
in all the endings we fight our way up
the alchemist's stronghold for a
climactic battle with the head of the
Alchemists Simon pistries Manus Simon is
the main cause for the petrification
disease spreading throughout crop he
used the resulting Ergo to try to become
a new evolved life form that would usher
in a world without lies he definitely
had deep-seated issues from childhood
but I don't want to delve further into
that here since he is the same in all
the endings his story and the trials of
krot are just the backdrop for the more
real or personal story going on with our
character and Geppetto after defeating
Manus and traveling down the elevator
there is a chance to get any one of
three different endings two of them are
extremely similar and one is more
distinct and darker I will start with
that last one the ending is titled real
boy they all lived happily ever after
this ending can be acquired regardless
of what choices you make throughout the
game all you have to do is hear at the
end choose to give Geppetto your your
heart when he asks for it he will then
take your heart out and put it into a
body he brought along in his box which
will then revive as a kind of evil or
destructive Carlo Carlo was the name of
Geppetto's real son and the name of the
writer of Pinocchio and his heart is the
one that powers your puppet body in game
we then see the new revived Carlo murder
everyone still remaining at hotel krot
at the behest of Geppetto all of our
friends and companions are slaughtered
in Cold Blood then they are replaced
with lifeless puppets who all exist to
serve us or Carlo and even in this
ending when Geppetto is reunited with
his long dead son the one who he kind of
abandoned in life he goes away again he
leaves a letter saying that he will make
krat safe for us talking about the
petrification disease like it's a minor
nuisance this ending is very obviously
bad coded the new Carlo seems to be a
puppet slave for Geppetto despite being
called a real boy the dream of the
original Pinocchio from the fairy tale
this Carlo kills the companions his
heart grew to trust and work with all
because he was asked or told to by
Geppetto an absentee father who we see
in memories the real Carlo hate it
we might get a human body of some kind
in this ending or otherwise become a
real person in some way but it is clear
we are really just a puppet dancing on
someone else's strength namely
Geppetto's Sophia remarks at the end
asking us
fair to say this is a bad ending and it
does give us the post-credits cutscene
but I want to wait to cover each ending
before delving into that
so we saw what happens when you give
your heart to Geppetto if on the other
hand you refuse his request you can get
one of two different endings if you
answer most of your choices throughout
the game by telling the truth you will
get what I want to call the good-ish
ending titled free from the puppet
string and just a note lots of the
online guides say different things about
how to get this and the next ending
claiming you need to always tell the
truth or always lie or other
requirements that I don't think are true
I know you can get the next Ending by
lying only most of the time you don't
need to always lie so I think you can
get this Ending by telling the truth
just most of the time and probably not
killing Sophia when she asks but I'm
less certain about that requirement so
once you refuse Geppetto he will release
the nameless puppet on you we learn from
its Ergo that the nameless puppet was
the first puppet made by the old man
that was mounted with a p organ but
because it was destructive it was not
chosen for the boy's body and sealed
away Geppetto takes it out as a last
resort to get the heart from us in his
dialogue we hear during the fight
Geppetto reveals that he gave us his son
Carlo's heart he didn't bind us to the
Grand Covenant the set of rules that
most puppets have to follow so that the
heart would grow while having Freedom
this was so it could one day be used to
revive the real Carlo and that he
wouldn't be burdened by the grand
Covenant I assume we learned earlier in
the game that puppets are powered by
Ergo which can come from people
especially those afflicted by the
petrification disease sometimes a human
ego can awaken within a puppet
especially if the puppet looks like the
original person Geppetto likely tried
this with our puppet body but as he
points out we never got Carlos memories
though if we did we would probably hate
Geppetto anyways so probably not too
good of a plan for him while we don't
have his memories Geppetto remarks how
he did inherit Arlo's personality since
I suppose Carlo was
mischievous
that's not enough so Geppetto wants to
use Carlo's heart a whole mess of Ergo
and the arm of God artifact to make the
new Psycho Killer Carlo we see in the
bad ending and if that's his ideal
version Geppetto probably doesn't want
the real Carlo back anyways blinded by
his grief and possibly just a selfish
person in general he just wants the
puppet version of Carlo he sees in his
head one who will come live as a family
with him and do what he says as his
father once the nameless puppet gets to
phase two we anime slice its head off
and it erupts in Golden Ergo losing the
strings Geppetto controlled it with once
we beat its second phase we get a
cutscene where it gets to beat us in
combat Lane it is about to stab us
through the heart but Geppetto stops IT
the puppet is destructive so it just
wants to body us but Geppetto can't let
any harm come to Carlo's heart or he
might have to actually face the fact
that his son is dead and stop running
away from it we then turn into gigachad
and destroy the nameless puppet's core
so far all of this has been exactly like
what we will see in the next ending the
differences start as Geppetto Keels over
and we go to support him in this ending
as we hold the dying Geppetto he says
all right
no
you're just useless
a puppet
then he dies this ending concludes here
save for the post-credit scene we will
get to later Geppetto's final line will
make more sense when we look at the
final ending but in short it is about
how he views us as nothing more than a
puppet puppets are supposed to never lie
and in this playthrough we tell the
truth more than we lie so we basically
act like a puppet we are free from
Geppetto strings as the name of the
ending suggests but if we want to really
see what it's like to leave behind the
shackles of puppetdum we must look at
the final ending
the last ending to lies of p is a rhyme
to the game's title it's called rise of
P you can get this ending like the
previous one by refusing to give
Geppetto your heart the difference is
that throughout your playthrough you
need to have lied most of the time and
you likely need to have given Sophia
peace when she asks though again I'm not
as 100 sure on that once this ending
begins it is the same as the free from
the puppet string ending up until
gerpetto's death here he still saves us
from nameless but once we are holding
him something else happens the camera
shows a tear running down our cheek
Geppetto recognizes this and says
foreign
sorry
before dying I took this to be about how
the line throughout the game has made us
more human it has caused our heart to
grow to the point that we are
essentially a real human who can feel
human emotions in this final moment
either our character developed an
attachment for Geppetto or Carlo's heart
moves within us and cries at his
father's death even if he didn't like
him Carlo might still be moved to see
Geppetto pass Geppetto's words recognize
this they show that he now sees us as
his son Carlo even if we may not have
his memories we have become a real human
who can feel and we feel his death like
a human would
then we get another cutscene before the
credits apparently there's a ready-made
Sophia puppet maybe not too weird
considering Manus was kind of obsessed
with her and we give Ergo to that puppet
returning the favor from the beginning
of the game when Sophia gave us ergo
the Sophia puppet wakes up as we pass
out and she says it's so good to see you
this Echoes her first words to us at the
game's beginning
the credits we can explore and find a
note from her but before we get to that
there is the post-credits scene to
discuss
after the credits we find the man who
called himself giangio on a train janjio
is the name of one of the characters in
the original Pinocchio story what we see
here that the character is actually
called paracelsus and he is
communicating with someone from an
outside organization philippus
paracelsus or paracelsus is the name of
a real world Swiss physician Alchemist
and philosopher from the 1500s when we
first met janjio he pretended to be an
alchemist pretending to be a pharmacist
and he talks about how the dose of a
substance determines if it's a medicine
or a poison which is an idea attributed
to the real paracelsus in our world so
this basically confirms the name as a
reference the org he talks to has an
interest in kinds of humanity and
eternal light they mention us as a kind
of brother or new Humanity maybe we are
a new kind of immortal or Eternal being
this new human puppet life form that we
have become and this might be a reach
but his hair color is a bit like like
ours after being influenced by Sophia
and Sophia mentions her powers being
time related which would tie into the
themes about eternity on the call the
voice notes that
which could be a reference to our
mechanical arm that's the first most
obvious one but I think that doesn't
make sense since we learned that the
legion arm is a creation of Geppetto and
Modified by venini it is more likely
that the eternals are talking about the
arm of God the item we get when we
defeat Manus this item let Mr eugenics
in some way summon a god-like being in
the sky and its description talks about
being a mysterious Relic even to the
Alchemists so this mysterious
organization of eternals is likely
interested in this God arm and
apparently they had it before if they
want to get the arm back who or whatever
that God is this organization is likely
closer to it than anything else in crop
except maybe for one new character
paracelsus ends his cutscene saying he
will find another key to the
organization Dorothy
and then the camera focuses on an
obscured book The Design shown is the
first edition cover of The Wizard of Oz
which has Dorothy is the main character
then in a shot on the rooftops of crot
we see someone walking in ruby slippers
before they click their heels three
times this is another reference to Oz
where Dorothy Must acquire the ruby
slippers and click her heels three times
to return to her home of Kansas maybe
this Dorothy was scouting crot out and
is now returning to her home which I'm
assuming isn't plain old Kansas but
maybe that's her base of operations this
could be a reference to a DLC or a
sequel or more fairy tale characters
come into play as part of the world of
eternals a YouTube comment I saw pointed
out that tin man one of the other main
characters of Wizard of Oz was looking
for a heart and a metal puppet with a
heart like the character we play as
could fit as that character maybe
Dorothy was scoping us out to possibly
get us to join her crew we don't know
what form this will take but with the
etern internals organization out there
plotting something there's likely some
grander conflict that we will learn
about and maybe be pulled into whether
that's by Dorothy paracelsus or someone
else there is definitely some greater
story that is being hinted at but we
will have to wait and see to learn
what's really going on and to wrap
things up the game lets us keep playing
after the cutscenes and credits we can
see that everyone in the hotel is
thankful that the trials of the game are
over and they're all real people in the
zendi not puppets Sophia leaves a note
marveling that an ergo puppet can become
a new form of human that's us and she
says she will stay away for the time
being we get the option to jam out on
the piano in the hotel and we can also
find another letter left by paracelsus
at his old location near the gold coin
fruit tree he expresses excitement at
our development and he talks about
meeting on the Eternal line of time he
signs off PP which confirms that he is
named after the real philippus
paracelsus the note about time again
make me think of Sophia when she talked
about how her power is related to time
and this makes me think that the Hair
Connection Isn't So far-fetched so there
we have each of the endings of lies of P
explain let me know in the comments if
you have any more questions about the
endings that have been left unanswered
if you like this content you can
subscribe and or support me on patreon
thanks to my patrons for their support
thanks to you for watching and I'll see
you again in the next video peace